So there's really two rules for building fluid layouts. Use
percentages or viewport units, something that'll size as you resize
the window. And then, test while you're resizing the window.
Let's take a look at how this worked out on
the mobile device. We went from this layout without any
changes to my blog. To this layout, definitely an improvement.
I don't have to scroll left or right to see
everything on the screen. And, you may notice the font size
is actually a bit larger now. The font size
was always set in M units, although it's actually still
a bit small for a mobile device. So, we
should probably bump that up. Let's take a look on
the tablet. In the tablet layout, we went from
this layout to this, again, a definite improvement. This is
actually a pretty readable experience. And, even when we
rotate the screen, we end up with a nice reformatting.
All this is really just a long winded way of
saying, be sure to create fluid layouts. Be sure to
reflow to use all the space on the screen and
take advantage of every bit you can. And be sure
you adapt to different screens as well. One tool that
makes reflow a lot easier, particularly across very different screen
sizes, is the new flex box layout in CSS. This
new tool let's you stack elements in flexible rows or columns.